I want to start with congrats on the
movie uh it's going to be a huge hit I'm
sure everyone knows that already what
really was what I was really surprised
was that I wasn't sure with Dwayne how
hard he was going to go because of like
his family-friendly kind of personality
and like but he kills a ton of people in
this and really is Black Adam he commits
he's full-on and so I'm just for both of
you though were you a little bit like
like he really he kills everyone like
all the bad guys are just done yeah no
we like that because we we want him to
eradicate inner gang we want him to kill
the bad guys
um but yeah no I think his performance
as Black Adam is just seamless you know
he's got such a great body of work
behind him but in my opinion he
completely disappears in this role you
do not you don't see Dwayne Johnson you
don't see the rock you don't see that
you see a full-on mythological character
a comic book character come to life in
my opinion and the deadpan delivery is
just like you know as a comedian I
really was pleasantly surprised right I
didn't know how he was going to play and
how he was going to go when we filmed
the scene in the apartment that was the
first thing we filmed together and just
seeing him deliver such really harsh
yeah lines and things to say like just
kill them
it just took me a second to to
recalibrate and like oh wow this is
gonna be amazing just to see him in that
and you're right you just completely uh
you know he obviously has a body of work
but you don't see the rock you see Black
Adam truly um I love learning about like
the behind the scenes of the making of a
film what do you think soon to be fans
of Black Adam are going to be surprised
to learn about the actual making of the
movie
that's a really good question no that is
good um I think the I think the years
that it took to get there is really
fascinating to me like as just as a
Creator it's it's people just see the
final product and they're like wow you
know you did that and then when they
understand that this is for DJ has been
a 10 year years in the making yeah
somebody who's had the level of success
that he's had for him to still struggle
to work through it and be have the
patience to assemble such a great team
and a cast together with all the
producers and Warner Brothers is a
testament to them and and I think that's
like really to me like the meat of the
story
um in the background we just had a ball
like we had a ball making it we were
jamming music all the time people
hanging out in my trailer
raiding my nose sleepovers rating my
snacks sleepovers barbecues that's
really like I think the the secret to
making anything great is the chemistry
yeah truly being a family and man we're
very very close yeah is there anything
that you wanted to add
I mean I you know everything that he
said yes just sort of the the Manpower
that it takes to get something like this
off the ground but then also you know I
myself was pretty tickled to learn what
it takes to film a movie like this I'd
never done anything like this before so
just you know the the green screen
element you know it's like a lot we had
we had fight scenes to do but there was
nobody in front of us either because
they were going to be skeletons CGI
didn't later so it's going
like over and over again until like
nothing you know it ruined my wrist yes
I was just throwing that collie stick
everywhere it's like somebody's got to
be there yeah this is like a child and
then it'd be cut and you look around
there's like 500 people staring at you
yeah yeah yeah dude make believe you're
like right that was awesome
but it was so yeah just stuff like that
and the green screen and then you know
the wire work and a lot of and there
were a couple scenes where my character
we were in an ensemble scene where
everybody was there but for whatever
reason we didn't have time to shoot my
coverage so we shot everybody else out
by the time it came for like my
close-ups nobody was able to be there
for me so I had to do a lot of my scenes
to a wall basically or just like you
know a golf ball that somebody would
move around to play tennis balls tennis
balls and so that was that's also
something that was like I don't know
it's really challenging and as it tells
me to Sarah just being such a phenomenal
artist and well I don't know about that
but I don't know about that no you don't
like you have to use your imagination
I'm just saying that's something that I
feel like if had I seen that in like a
behind the scenes whatever I wouldn't
have thought oh wow so she was by
herself when she did that huh you know I
have to wrap I'm just gonna say people
would be people don't really realize
what it takes behind the scenes with
scheduling with that kind of stuff like
it's just crazy how movies are made sure
I know I know no there's a ton of moving
Parts a ton of moving parts and you have
to just go with it and you don't have
any time but like can I have a second no
no it's not an awesome domino effect
yeah you better be ready your second's
gonna cost me a million dollars let's go
exactly on that note congratulations I
know it's going to be a huge hit have a
fantastic day